So now that we have an idea
of what POMDPs are about.
Maybe we should talk a little bit
about what it might mean to do
reinforcement learning in them because
we basically talked about planning.
If we have a model of the POMDP we can
run some calculations we can run value
iteration to get a way of deciding
what to do actually did I say that?
I think I did not say that.
I think what I said is how
you get a value function.
Is it clear how you would use
a value function to get a policy?
>> In the same way you would for
an MDP right?
Yes? No? That's not true?
>> Yeah that's right.
If you have the model, then you can
use one step look ahead with the value
function to figure out what the optimal
action is in any given believe state.
Once we've run valuation and gotten
an approximation of the optimal value
function, and what about that valuation
doesn't actually necessarily converge.
>> It doesn't?
You didn't tell me that.
>> I did actually when we
do in less than triple a.
>> Lesson triple a?
>> Yeah the advanced algorithm analysis.
Well we said there is that value
iteration converges in the limit
to the right value function but
after any finite number of steps it need
not have the optimal value function.
But it will after some finite number
of steps have the optimal policy
that's not going to be true in the POMDP
case because there's an infinite number
of states.
>> I see.
>> But
it is going to be the case that
we get an arbitrarily good
approximation after some
finite number of iterations.
>> Wait arbitrarily good
approximation of what?
>> Of the optimal value function.
>> Wait but
not necessarily optimal policy?
>> Yeah if you do one step back ups or
one step look ahead
with a near optimal value function
you get a near optimal policy?
>> Okay so that's nearly good.
>> [LAUGH] Now that we've
talked about planning in POMPDs
we should talk about
reinforcement learning in POMPDs.
>> Charles, what's the difference
between planning and
reinforcement learning?
>> Well, in planning you know everything
in a reinforcement learning you
don't know everything and
you have to explore and exploit and
do all that other stuff in
order to find things out like
you don't know the model necessarily and
that makes the problem harder so
what you're telling me is reinforcement
learning is harder then planning
in the way you're using the words
>> And
POMDPs are more difficult
to deal with than MDPs.
So reinforcement learning in POMDPs
should be like, is that additive,
multiplicative?
>> So reinforcement
learning in POMDPs is hard.
>> Hm.
>> Like, super hard.
Actually planning in POMDPs is formally
undecidable in the sense that [LAUGH]
>> Undecidable?
>> Yeah,
[LAUGH] if I give you a POMDP and
ask, is this the optimal first action
to take from this belief state?
If you could solve that problem you
could solve the halting problem.
>> Holy cow!
>> Wait, wait a minute, wait a minute,
wait a minute, wait a minute.
That has profound implications.
>> No, it doesn't.
>> Yes it does,
because we're human beings
running around in the world
we're living in a POMDP because
we can't know everything.
So you telling me that even
if I could relive life
an infinite number of times I still
don't know what the right thing to do is
you're saying that life is unknowable.
It's undecidable you can
never know what to do.
That's profound.
Wow I need a moment.